All right, let's talk about the Super Bowl,
because I have so many thoughts,
and I literally had to write things down
because I have so many thoughts.
My first year watching a Super Bowl,
because I never watched this stuff.
I know it's satanic,
I don't watch it.
Um, this is my first year watching it,
and everything that I've always said and thought
has been proven watching it.
Number one is
I noticed how all the players,
um. Well, not all.
There's one that doesn't do this,
but all the players mentioned god always
and not Jesus.
They never mentioned Jesus.
And if they do,
the one player that did,
they took out that part of the interview at the end
where he mentioned Jesus. Um,
they don't wanna tell you what god they're worshipping.
They want you to think
that they're worshipping the same god as you.
So you're like, oh, my god.
Yes. Like, no,
it's not what you think.
It's not the god that you think they're worshipping.
Um, and that's why they.
We just say god.
So Brock Party actually
was the one that,
um, mention Jesus in his.
In his interview.
And of course,
they cut in half.
Of course they don't want you to see that. Of course.
Of course they.
They take that out.
Did you guys see the upside down cross?
That devil horns that.
I spiced it
because I clearly saw it.
And I saw it,
and I was Like, yep.
Like, of course
they're gonna try to
once the cameras on them
to do all this wicked stuff
to show you, um,
the god that they're worshipping,
um, the devil.
Um, of course.
Like, of course they're gonna do that. Uh,
there were so many signs,
truly. Like, the halftime show was filled with signs.
Satanic signs.
Um, the red. There's such a devil.
Um, there's an angel with fire around.
There was so many signs.
The Super Bowl Jesus commercial.
Oh, my goodness,
that commercial.
That commercial that, um,
it was like
basically people washing other people's feet and saying,
Jesus washed other people's feet
to not spread hate or whatever.
I have beef with that commercial.
Um, first of all,
Jesus washed his disciples feet. Um,
not what it's.
It's not about washing someone's feet, um,
while they reject what,
what god says.
Um, it's because if you truly,
truly love someone,
you share the gospel with them.
You don't just let them do,
you know, do all this stuff and, like,
not follow what god says.
You preach them the gospel.
You don't just wash their feet
while they're doing all this crazy stuff.
So I have beef with that commercial.
My biggest thing,
do not fear of this stuff.
Do not feel anxious of this stuff.
Because if you truly have Jesus in your life,
you know, you have peace.
Like, you have the peace that he brings.
Um, and my biggest thing is
Like this year,
open your Bible. More like
open your Bible more than you would use your phone.
Like, every time you're gonna use your phone
for something not important,
go to your Bible.
Read your Bible,
get in the word of god.
Because honestly,
nothing's gonna bring you peace,
especially in an election year
where there's gonna be chaos as much as Jesus will. So.